c'est l'amphithéâtre qui a vu le
fabuleux panier de la victoire le panis
historique de kauai lennon presse qu'à
pareille date l'an passé cette année le
tableau indicateur et éteint les gradins
sont déserts d'autres héros plus
importants ceux là sont à l'oeuvre d
être connecté à cette année c'est nous
l'équipe en séries éliminatoires blague
t-il sortie de l'aréna scotia banque est
devenue une cuisine géante 70 employés
cuisiner en baldé mais individuel dix
mille repas par jour on atteindra la
pleine capacité la semaine prochaine des
repas ensuite distribués aux plus
vulnérables comme les itinérants et
aussi aux travailleurs de la santé de
première ligne
c'est une forme de remerciement pour
leur dévouement de l'aide apprécié cet
hôpital de toronto
médecins et infirmières font la file
pour obtenir un repas sept employés
trouvent ces journées pénible elle est
d'autant plus ému et reconnaissante pour
cette attention celle-ci apportera le
repas à la maison pour le partager avec
ses deux enfants la moitié des mets
préparés à l'aréna prendront le chemin
des banques alimentaires refuges pour
itinérants et autres organismes
communautaires du grand toronto
les besoins sont criants et urgent
les demandes dead pendant cette pandémie
ont bondi de 7 100 % à toronto
ce sont des travailleurs précaires ou
mises à pied récemment dont un bon
nombre de personnes qui se tournent vers
une banque alimentaire pour la première
fois de telles initiatives d'urgence ne
devrait être qu'un premier pas vers de
l'aide durable selon le réseau pour une
alimentation durable
l'organisme réclame une révision des
modes de distribution de la nourriture
au pays
ici philippe le de la radio canada dont